problem 77
77
if miss smith's income was 20 more for
her 99 1991 than it was for 1990 how
much was her income in 1991
so 20 percent more in 19 for 1990 so
19 income
let's call it income 1991
is 20 percent more
than
then 1990 so that's means 1.2
times income in 1990. i hope you
you get that right if something is 20
more than something else is going to be
1.2 times that right 12 is 20 more than
10 and 12 is 1.2 times 10. right
or you could view it as income plus 20
of income which is 1.2 times income
either way so let's see what they tell
us
what do we have to figure out how much
was okay we're trying to figure out this
income in 1991.
statement number one
miss smith's income for the first six
months
of 1990 was 17 500 and the income for
the last six months of 1990
was twenty thousand dollars
well it seems so let's see they're
telling that she made seventeen thousand
five hundred in the first six months
of 1990 and her income for the last six
months of 1990 was 20 were 20 000.
well they're essentially telling us the
total income for 1990 right the first
six months in the last six months or 12
months in a year so her total income for
1990 was 37
500
that equals income for 1990.
so clearly if we know this is this we
just multiply that times 1.2 and we get
the income for 1991. so this statement
alone is sufficient let's see what they
give us for statement number two
miss smith's income for 1991 was 7 500
greater than for 1990. so they say
income
of 1991
was seventy five hundred so it equals
income for nineteen ninety
plus seventy five hundred
plus seventy five hundred
well this alone
well this alone does help us because
they already gave it given us this so we
have two linear equations right this is
one linear equation and two unknowns
this is another linear equation in two
unknowns so we have two linear equations
and two unknowns we can solve this
probably the easiest way is just to
substitute you could
depending what you want to solve for but
we've done that multiple times you could
substitute 1.2 times 1990 here and then
solve for it or you could do the other
way you could do divide by 1.2 here and
then substitute it there but either way
this is trivial algebra hopefully by
this point to solve but this and this is
definitely enough information to solve
the problem
so two equations with two unknowns and
you can do that in in your spare time
if you don't believe me
so both statements alone are sufficient
for this one
78
78 and the figure above so i think i
have to draw let me let me see if i can
see
this is the y-axis
that's the x-axis
and then they have a line
let's see what i can do
a line look something like that
and then they tell us
what do they tell us this is
of course this is y
this is x
and then they say this is
p
this right here
is q
and then
they draw this
they call this point right here r
and they drop that's like that and this
q is at point c
d
and p is at point
a
b
and then they say in the figure above
segments p r and q are so pr and qrs let
me draw that out a little bit better as
pr and qr
are each parallel to one of the
rectangular coordinate axes okay fair
enough
this is parallel to the y-axis pr is
parallel to the x-axis fair enough
is the ratio of the length of qr to pr
equal to 1
so the ratio of qr to pr is equal to 1.
so they want to know qr
over p r
is that equal to one
and immediately this should trigger
something from algebra one they're
asking you essentially is the slope of
this line equal to one right is the
ratio of qr to pr so rise over run is
the slope of this line equal to one
so let's see let's see what we can do
and slope is just you know you change in
y over change in x and well you know
this is changing so what's this point
first of all yes you don't have to know
anything about slope i don't want to
make you feel like you have to memorize
some formulas it's all
what's this point going to be
so it's going to be actually let's let's
let's do it even better what is
what is the length of qr going to be
this is i haven't looked at any of the
data points right now what is length of
qr
well it's going to be this height so
it's
this y which is d minus this y this y is
going to be b
right because all of this is
y is equal to b right here so qr is
going to be equal to d minus b
and pr
is the length on the x axis it's going
to be
it's going to be this x
right what is this x well this x is
right here c
x is equal to c is going to be this x
minus this x well here x is equal to a
and so the ratio
is equal to
d minus b
over c minus a which is the if you
remember the formula for the slope of a
line
you just take the y 1 minus y 2 over x 2
minus
sorry y 1 minus y2 over
x1 minus x2 but we we just we didn't
have to memorize that it's intuition
because this point right here r is the
point see the x coordinate is c and the
y coordinate is b
so hopefully that gives you the
intuition now let's look at the
statements you wouldn't have to do that
on the real gmat that would all be a
waste of time
statement number one tells us
c is equal to three and d is equal to
four
so that by itself
that just gives us the first part of
this that doesn't help us figure out
this entire ratio so this by itself
isn't that useful maybe in conjunction
with what else they give us
statement two
a is equal to
minus two and b is equal to minus
well if you use both of these statements
together then we have everything here
we have d
we have b
we have c
and we have a so we can solve it so both
statements together are sufficient for
solving for for knowing whether the
ratio of qr to pr is one or essentially
is the slope of this line
equal to one
next problem
79
79
while on a straight road car x and car y
are traveling at different constant
rates if car x is now one mile ahead of
car y
how many minutes from now will car x be
two miles
ahead of car y
so right now
let me see let me see if i can so x
x is here
y is here
and they're going at constant rates
one mile so they've been traveling for
some amount of time and x is one mile
ahead and they're saying how long is it
going to be before x is how many minutes
before x is two miles ahead and they're
at constant rates so if they start off
let's just think about if they started
off at the same point and it took ten
minutes for x to get one mile ahead it
would take
another ten minutes for it to get two
miles ahead well that's how i'm thinking
about it let's see what they give us for
the for the statements
statement number one
car x is traveling at 50 miles per hour
and car y is traveling at 40 miles per
hour well that's that seems to be pretty
good information car x
50
miles per hour
car y
is 40 miles per hour
so essentially car y is moving away from
car x at what it's moving away at 50
minus 40 miles per hour so if from car
at y's point of view car x is always
pulling away at 10 miles per hour
right does that make sense if car x was
going at 40 miles per hour they wouldn't
it wouldn't be pulling away at all if it
was going at 41 miles per hour it'd be
pulling away at a incremental one mile
per hour and you know as long as we're
not approaching the speed of light we
can assume newtonian classical physics
and we could just take the difference
between the two
so how long does it take for it to pull
away another
another
mile well how many minutes if you're
going 10 miles per hour relative to
something else how many minutes does it
take to go a mile well one you know you
can figure that out but let me figure
that out for you
so
you know distance is equal to rate times
time
so if your distance you want to know is
one mile
and your rate is equal to 10
miles per hour
10
miles per hour
times time what's the time going to be
equal time is going to be equal to
one
one tenth of an hour
or six minutes
so that's the answer number one one
alone is sufficient or the answer number
79 one alone is sufficient let's see
what they give us for number two
statement two three minutes ago car x
was one half mile ahead of car y
okay so
three minutes ago
the state of affairs was this
y was here
x was here
and
it was a half mile difference
so what does that tell us that's
actually pretty good information too
three minutes ago car x was half mile
ahead of car y
now car x is one mile ahead so in three
minutes
in three minutes
x
x pull you could say goes
pulls away by three
pulls
away
by half a mile
right and they're going at constant
velocity so there the relative
velocities between the two don't change
so if it takes three minutes for x to
pull away by half a mile
it would take six minutes for x to pull
away by a mile right just multiplying by
two they're they're all going at the
same constant velocities so six minutes
x pulls away
pulls away
by one mile
and that's actually what they're asking
because they say how many more minutes
does it take x to pull away by another
mile
they've probably been traveling for six
minutes already and then another six
minutes x would pull away by another
mile so two alone is also sufficient so
each of them independently are good
enough to answer this question see in
the next video